[MUSIC PLAYING]
JILL EBSTEIN: Thank
you for coming.
And think Google for
providing a forum
that people like me
can share our ideas.
So first I want to do is tell
you a little bit about the
"At My Pace" series.
This was the first book, in
case you guys did not see it.
And what caused me start with
"At My Pace", this whole idea,
was at the time Sheryl
Sandberg had her "Lean In"
conversation and everybody
was running with "Lean In",
except for a fair chunk
of my friends and people
I knew who felt it
didn't apply to them.
And the question
was, is there a story
to be told about women who
aren't on the autobahn going
full speed ahead?
Is there a story to be
told about those people who
have a windy road
with starts and stops
who are enjoying life in
a different kind of way?
And I could not find
a book out there
that laid credence to that.
And so I decided that we
would write that book.
And I had, as my model in the
back of my mind, the "This I
Believe" series.
Does anybody know
"This I Believe"?
It's really worth
checking out some time.
So they are 500-word, very
pithy pieces on different topics
that high school
students oftentimes read.
And you get a chance
to see the world
through many different
peoples' eyes.
But I knew that 500 words
would not capture the topics
that I was looking at.
So I said, let's bump it
up to a thousand words.
Let me do some guidelines
and let me help people.
I wanted people
who weren't famous
and people who don't
typically write.
I wanted to get those
voices out there.
It's the voices of the
people that most of us
interact with every day.
And the goal was
to see the world
through many different
perspectives,
at the end of the day, to
expand the conversation.
So that time it was
about leaning in
and the woman's journey,
which I since have learned it
shouldn't have been
the woman's journey.
It should have been the
journey, because we all
have the same challenges of
how we're going to do it.
And then at the end of it all,
in some way in that process
we would discover
something about ourselves
and find some truths that
would mean something to us.
And why it's "At My Pace"
is because, even though we
live in a fast-paced society,
finding out these truths
or working our way
through these issues
doesn't happen that quickly.
It's some organic process.
And my hope was that
these books would
help foster a conversation
that will get to that place
that we can feel
good about the topic.
So that was the first book.
I continued to give lots of
discussion groups on that.
But the second book-- so
then what was happening
was I was thinking, is
there another book in me?
And my mother was in
her 91st year of life,
and she wasn't doing that well.
And so she lived
in Denver and I'd
fly in and see her
every five or six weeks.
I would be there.
I was always driving
her crazy with,
are you drinking enough,
are you eating enough,
and how's the PT going?
And just like your teenagers can
sort of shut you down and sort
of--
she was basically not wanting
to engage in that conversation.
So I decided I would
change the conversation.
And I wrote her a
piece on one lesson
I took from her life
and its impact on me.
And that lesson was about
continuous lifelong learning.
In her 80s, she was
still taking classes.
She had very young
classmates in her class.
One of the classes they
gave her a rolling backpack
because they were afraid
that she would fall as she
tried to carry these books.
And so it's my mother's rolling
backpack, that even in her 80s
she's taking classes.
And I realized that,
for me, I'm always--
you know, I wasn't
always working on my own.
I worked in different
established companies.
And I was always told
how curious I was.
And I think that curiosity
and that wanting to learn
came from her.
So I wrote my piece.
And then she loved it.
And then I thought, well, this
is going to be my next book.
I'm going to go ask people to
write a piece on their mother,
only one lesson,
not 10, story based,
and it cannot be mushy gushy.
That was just me because I'm
not a big mushy gushy fan.
So it turns out that mushy
gushy was really not that much
in the cards anyway
because people
have very complex feelings
about their mothers,
oftentimes-- not
always, oftentimes.
So I'm going to show you
the cover of the book.
This was the cover,
as you have it there.
And my question to
you is, what do you
think I was thinking when I
had a fledgling with a flower
and a mother bird looking down?
What do you think
was in my thoughts?
OK, I'm going to help you guys.
AUDIENCE: Judgement.
JILL EBSTEIN: What was it?
JILL EBSTEIN: Gratitude.
This fledgling had a
flower, and to me, it
was a sign of giving
back, a saying thank you.
Now it turns out that
sometimes it's not a flower.
Sometimes it's an olive branch.
Sometimes it's putting
your mother in context
and being able to
explain her to yourself
and being able to validate
that relationship.
And I mentioned that I
have guidelines when I go
through this with contributors.
And this guideline I said,
you may not dis your mom.
If it turns out that you cannot
get to that place that you can
put her in context
and appreciate her,
then it's not the book for you.
And some people couldn't.
I had one woman who wrote
me and she said, "I've tried
three times to write my piece.
It is still a rant.
So I thank you because I'm
going to see a therapist now."
And we were just
talking about dogs.
I have a dog that
I love dearly and I
went to take him to my groomer.
I said, "Oh, by the
way, I got this book.
How would you like
one of these books?"
And she's like,
"It's about moms."
I'm like, yep.
"I have a really complicated
relationship with my mom."
I'm like, "Well, you
don't have to take it."
"No, no worries, I was just--
no, I'll take them"
I've been a customer.
She probably felt obliged.
And then when I came back the
next go around she said to me,
"That was so meaningful
because I have never
been at peace with my mom.
I read the book.
I wrote a piece."
She and I cried.
It was a very healing moment.
So I had a lot of
things like that happen.
So what I want
today is two things.
I want to talk about the
flower and the olive branch,
the people who just had
sort of sheer appreciation,
and the olive branch, the people
who really had to struggle
to put their mother in context,
and give you guys a feeling--
let me get my reading glasses
so I can actually read a little
bit--
and give you guys a
feeling for what I heard
and what I took
away from it all.
So do we want to hear olive
branches or flowers first?
OK, if you guys aren't
voting I'm going for flowers.
All right, so there's a story
here called "Rough Patch".
And "Rough Patch"-- it's
written by Laurel Lloyd--
is a woman whose mother,
when she was young,
all she wanted to do was drama.
Now her parents, one was a
teacher, one was a nurse.
And she lived in
that stage of living
where parents seem to be
able to actually dictate
what their kids did.
And so her parents said to her,
you can do drama on the side,
but you're not going to do that.
You're going to be a teacher.
That's a nice, solid career.
You can support yourself.
So she taught, but
she didn't like it.
And she ended up
reverting back to drama,
and that's what she did.
And then one summer when
she was doing drama,
she met what would become
her husband on the stage.
At the end of the summer
they were engaged,
and they then went
ahead and had four kids.
They left New York City
and they headed to Vermont
and they raised their kids in
a very small town in Vermont.
He had a small hardware store.
She was a mom who did
PTA and Girl Scouts
and sort of a traditional role.
She didn't have too
much time to act,
almost no time, a
little bit occasionally.
He was still doing
acting on the side.
And Laurel remembers
that somewhere
in the 20-year mark
of their marriage,
they hit this rough patch.
And at 23 years in their
marriage, they got divorced.
When he was on stage in one of
his shows, he met an actress.
They fell in love.
And that was the end of
his marriage to his wife.
So Laurel describes that moment
when she says about her mother,
"She felt rejected and alone.
But at age 50 she picked
herself up and moved forward.
In the years that
followed, my mother
acted in multiple theaters
outside of our town.
She got a degree in
counseling, worked
as a counselor in a local high
school and at a local shelter
with teens.
She became the caretaker of
a refugee Guatemalan family,
helping to raise five children
while working at a Benedictine
monastery.
In time, her
relationship with my dad
healed, and they
often chatted when
seeing each other in town."
Now the weird thing
is that Laurel's
telling this story
as an adult. She
was married for 20 years,
hit the same rough patch.
And literally 23 years into
her marriage, at age 50,
she gets divorced.
Actually divorced, goes
through on the exact day
of what would have been
her parents' anniversary.
And so she's feeling
all over again,
like remembering her
mother and the pain.
And she describes,
"With a young daughter,
it was inevitable that I'd be
seeing my ex and eventually
his wife," because
her ex also had
a new woman, who actually
moved into the house
that Laurel moved out of.
"So I braced myself and
put my best foot forward.
I went back to work and
began to rebuild my life.
Five years since our
split, my ex and I
have moved beyond
our difficult time.
My goal during the
hurt of the divorce
was that we would find our
way back to a positive place.
And it has happened.
I even had Thanksgiving
dinner at my former home
this past year with my ex,
his wife, her ex, their son,
my daughter, and
some other guests."
And she concludes.
She said, "My friend
stifled a gasp
when I told her I'd
be having Thanksgiving
dinner with my ex and his wife.
But isn't that how
it should be, letting
go of the adversity
in our lives,
appreciating the good in
what was, and moving on?
In the end, it's the
children who win.
And that's the lesson that my
mother taught me with the grace
and kindness she showered
on those in her life, a gift
that I'll be sure to
pass on to my daughter."
So the same rough patch
that her mother had
was the same rough
patch that she had.
And she was able to take
her mother's equanimity
and strength and copy that
when she had her moment.
By the way, feel free to
ask questions or interject
with a comment.
This is supposed to be
informal and interactive.
OK, I'll give you another story.
That's what I call
a flower story.
This is a shorter one.
So the story is that Elise
Friedman, who's in her 70s,
remembers being in Maui,
traveling with her husband,
super excited to get up early
in the morning and go tour
the island.
And they're up very early.
And they're stuck in
traffic because there
is a big dump truck
filled with pineapples
that's blocking the road.
She said just filled
with pineapples.
So she's sort of laughing
at the peculiarity,
up early to go see the
island and here you
are in traffic because
of a truck of pineapples.
And she calls her mother
who lives in Buffalo.
Now first of all, she's
on her cell phone.
This is the 70s.
And her mother first
was like in shock.
Oh my gosh, you're
calling me from Hawaii
on her phone in Buffalo.
So that was sort of cool.
Then when they got
through that, Elise says,
"But mom, I'm calling you
because we are stuck in traffic
because there is a dump
truck in front of us filled
with pineapples."
And so her mother
says, "Well Elise,
have you tried the pineapples?"
To which Elise says, "Mom, you
know I don't eat pineapple."
Elise describes
herself as the person
who always fished the
pineapple out of any fruit cup
before she would even start
to have the fruit cup.
And her mother says,
"Elise, be a grownup.
Try the pineapple."
So she actually decides
to listen to her mother
and she tries the
pineapple later that day.
And she finds out that lo and
behold, the pineapple in Hawaii
is way different than any
pineapple she's ever tasted.
And then she later that day
goes to one of those gift stores
where they can find that
exact kind of pineapple
that she can ship to her mother.
So she does that.
And she heads back home.
And then two weeks
later she gets a call
from her sister in Buffalo.
And her sister says that their
mother has just had a stroke.
So Elise immediately goes
to Buffalo to visit the mom.
And at the end of the day,
she goes to her apartment.
And she opens up the fridge
to go get some water,
and there she sees the
pineapple, uneaten,
never to be eaten by her mother
who can't swallow anymore,
right there, unwrapped.
And she has a very big learning
moment for herself right there.
And I'm going to
say it in her words.
She writes, "I have a
tendency to be rather
emphatic in my
opinions, some of which
I may have formed
without a whole lot
of reasonable evidence.
Every so often I am in the
midst of holding forth,
explaining why I would
never, ever consider
doing this or that.
And then I hear my
mother cautioning me.
Elise, she is saying,
be a grownup."
So for her, the pineapple
was about opening up her mind
and really taking
the world fresh
and not bringing her
prejudices to that instance.
So those are some
flower stories.
Anybody have a lesson
they want to share
about their mother,
something that they
took that was on the
sweet side of life?
Do we want some
olive-branch stories?
OK, we'll go for an
olive-branch story.
So there's a story in this book
called "Emotional Blinders".
And it's the story of a man
named Martin Abramowitz who's
in his 70s.
His father was a cutter for
the Triangle Shirt Factory.
Does anybody know about
the Triangle Shirt Factory?
That was a factory that-- it
was a moment of tragedy, went up
in fire and many, many
young girls were killed.
I don't remember what the
year was, but it was--
AUDIENCE: Early 19.
JILL EBSTEIN: Early 1900s.
His father was a
cutter for the factory.
He remembers his father
was not a well man.
He was in and out
of the hospital.
Marty remembers
visiting him but not
being able to go
into the hospital
because they don't let
kids into the hospital.
He would have to
be on the outside,
sort of at the window waving.
And Marty has an older
brother, 10 years older.
So one day his mother tells
him that his father has
gone to Florida to convalesce.
And he sort of takes
it at face value.
He remembers that day.
It turned out to be the
day of his dad's funeral,
but the mother has
lied and told him
that the father has moved
to Florida to convalesce.
He says, "I remember
what I'm sure was
the day of that funeral.
My brother walked me to school
on that rainy March morning.
I still see the expanding
raindrop circles
in the puddles on our
block and feel the sadness
as I put my boots
and raincoat away
in the walk-in
closet at the back
of my second-grade classroom."
And that's all he remembers, no
funeral, no visitors at home,
no weeping mother, no
words of huge or hugs
or consolation or
processing of any kind.
And he proceeds along this path
that his dad is in Florida.
And two years pass, no phone
calls, no letters, no anything.
And finally he
goes to his mother
and he says, "Daddy
is dead, isn't he?"
And what he explains then
is the impact of that lie.
"Because I had
absorbed the lesson
of my mother's decision--
don't acknowledge death,
don't notice pain, don't pay
attention to any feelings--
a low-level, won't-go-away
sadness that you won't put
into words works as a strategy
to avoid pain and get through
life."
But that has an impact on
every profession in his life,
because he describes
as an older person,
he was a failed partner,
a failed parent.
He couldn't find any
real energy for life.
He has a very active
mind, but there was just
a lethargy about how he did
life because he had so learned
to repress his feelings.
And when I asked him if he
wanted to write a piece,
he wanted to write a piece
because it was his chance
to explain to himself
and to his children
and to his grandchildren
why his mother did that.
And he saw it in a
whole different light.
And he was able to find
some peace for himself.
So I'm going to read to you how
he puts this in perspective.
He says, "I have come to
understand Rosie's decision
through a different lens,
one that has a much more
positive lesson.
A widow at 42 with
one acting out
17-year-old son and the
other a frail seven-year-old,
and no income except
Social Security.
Rosie seems to have put
on emotional blinders.
She never bewailed
her situation,
never looked for a man.
Instead, she set
about making sure she
could support her family by
hand-sewing labels on men's
neckties.
My brother and I
have that memory
of trying to keep up with her
as she would go full speed ahead
navigating the
aisles of Macy's, not
looking back to see if we
were even keeping pace.
So Rosie's decision
to avoid pain
was also about getting on
with the business of life.
She was smart
enough to know that,
at some instinctive level,
what she needed to do
was to keep her family
and our lives intact.
I have enormous respect for
her ability to have done that
and to have taught
me a survival skill,
even as I mourn her
losses and mine."
So I asked him
why he wrote this.
I mean, he's been living
with this for many years.
I think for him,
He really wanted
to codify that experience, what
it meant to him at the time,
what it means to him now, and
how he can love and respect
her decisions even if, for a
very large chunk of his life,
it had some very
detrimental effects on him.
AUDIENCE: It's hard
not to be judgmental.
JILL EBSTEIN: It's hard not
to be judgmental, very hard.
AUDIENCE: It seems really
tough for a mother to not--
JILL EBSTEIN: Yeah,
right, and to see--
I mean, and also that older
brother who knew, right?
Can you mentioned being the
brother, 17-year-old brother,
10 years older who
knew [INAUDIBLE]
and had to actually
keep the lie as well.
So there's probably
a lot of ways
to unpack that that was
damaging in a lot of ways.
I had a woman--
so I always try in these
stories to reach out
to groups that are
not Newton Jewish.
That's sort of my sweet
spot, Newton Jewish,
but I try to reach out to
other parts of the universe.
I was much more successful
in the second book,
in this book, than I
was in the first book,
and successful again
in the third book.
So I reached out to a
woman who is from Guyana.
And her parents-- her
mother was a little more--
on the social caste
of society, her mother
was higher on the
rung than her father.
They lived in Guyana.
Her father was a police
officer who made his way up to,
I think, a military
officer of some kind.
They had four daughters.
And at some point their
parents get divorced.
And she is now living with her
mother and her grandmother.
And she misses her
father terribly.
And so the father
decides every Saturday,
he's going to come
visit the four daughters
and he's going to have
a good day with them.
And this happens routinely.
And so it's all very copacetic.
And then one Saturday
when he's visiting,
a military truck comes by
and says to her father,
you have to go.
And so he zooms away.
And it turns Guyana was
in the middle of a coup,
and he was on the side of
trying to repress the coup.
And he had to go see if
he could repress the coup.
In the course of
the coup, he died.
He was killed.
So now she has her
mother, her grandmother.
And then what happens
is, the mother remarries.
And I don't know what
the name of this man
is because he is only referred
with a capital H as Him.
Sort of like Lord Voldemort,
he who shall not be named,
it's Him.
And Him is abusive.
I'm not sure if it's
emotional or physical or both,
but he's definitely abusive.
And she is very
angry at her mother
because her mother never
stands up for them.
The grandmother is
a big believer in--
has a big belief in faith and
God, goes to church every week,
sings in the choir.
And the grandmother
says to this woman,
you will find your
salvation in the Lord.
You are meant to serve the Lord.
You will take your
pain and all this,
and that will be
where you put it.
And so she goes to
church and she sings
and she loves all that.
And at a certain
point, she decides
she's going to the
States because she
has to get away from Him, and
she's angry at her mother.
And she's able to come
here and she actually
does become a reverend.
Now when I asked
her if she would
write a story about her
mother, I didn't know all this.
I just knew that she
kept on saying to me,
"How about my grandmother?
Can I write about
my grandmother?"
And I said, "Well you can,
but it's a book about mothers.
But if grandmothers are what
you want to honor, fine,
we can do that."
And then I don't hear from her.
And as usually happens in "At
My Pace", you cast a big net
and you get some
eel, but some people
drop out for different reasons.
And I thought she was
going to drop out.
And then she calls me and
she says, "I'm coming over."
And she walks into my house.
She's a reverend.
And she says to me, "The
Lord has brought you to me."
And I thought that I was like
in a dreamland imagining this.
And she says again, "The
Lord has brought you to me."
And I went, "What did I do?"
And what I did was make
her revisit her past
and make her find
peace with her mother.
And so I'm going to
read you the end.
She calls her piece "Peace".
She actually called
me recently and said,
"I have some 30-somethings.
Can they write in your
20-something book?"
I'm like, "Nope,
it's 20-somethings.
But when I do 30-somethings,
I'll come back to you."
So here's what she writes
at the end of "Peace".
She writes, "It is
over four decades later
and today I am a reverend.
I have moved my mom to the
States and Him has died.
I have two children, and
while I am not their friend,
I am their ear.
I support and guide them,
and my second husband
is also committed to them.
I thank the Lord daily
and I have forgiven my mom
for not supporting my sisters
and me after my dad died.
It has taken a while, but
I have found my peace.
And hopefully she
has found hers."
So that is a pure
olive-branch story.
That is somebody who had
a lot of consternation,
a lot of anger, and was able
to, in the course of writing
a piece, find her peace.
So I think what's interesting to
me is, I speak about this book
to groups--
synagogues, community
places, you name it--
but I haven't had a chance to
take it into the work setting,
even though I've wanted to.
And I think that the
lessons from our mothers
applies as much to work as it
does into any community setting
you could, because we take our
lessons from our mom with us.
For good or for
bad, they are us,
and that's what
we bring to work.
And I had this
lunch a while back
where I was telling one of
my clients about the book,
and he pulls out his cell phone.
Now he works in a
technology company.
He has about 300 people in his
organization that he manages.
And he shows me that whenever he
feels overwhelmed or just sort
of daunted by the challenges,
he looks at this note
that his mother handwrote
for him years ago.
So his mother was an
immigrant from Ireland.
She came over when she was 16.
She knew nobody.
There was an Irish
community here in Boston.
That was helpful.
She became a clerk
at Jordan Marsh
and she worked all her
way up executive buyer.
And she wrote for her two kids
this thing called the ladder
of success, and he showed me.
"I think I will, I can, I did."
And it has percentages by it.
And so he looks at
that handwritten note
when he feels like
the world's just
a little bigger than he wants
it to be, or a little harder.
And when I asked him
what that was about,
he tells me two stories.
The first story is that they
went to church every Sunday.
And when they went
to church, there
would be a series of
people from a halfway house
in the back of the church.
And the first thing
she would do is
she would go up and shake
everybody's hand that
is part of the halfway house.
Evidently that was unusual,
because most people
didn't do that.
And she offered people
afterwards rides home.
And he said he took
from that the way
she was able to extend dignity
and respect to everybody,
no matter your lot in life.
And that was something he
wanted to make sure he copied.
The second memory he
had was on July 4.
Before they could go to the
big parade and celebrate,
she said, you have to clean up.
And it wasn't cleaning
up inside the house,
it was cleaning up outside.
And it wasn't just cleaning
up the lawn and the sidewalk.
It was going down
the block and seeing
if there was any garbage,
any refuse to pick up.
Because she wanted him to
understand that accountability
was more than just
about your area here.
It was about really
extending a much bigger arm
and being able to
take responsibility
for a bigger piece of the
world than just your lot.
So he looks at this
ladder of success
and he thinks about
how he treats people.
And he thinks about how
he builds accountability
within his teams.
And that's his lesson from his
mother that he takes into work.
So now I'm going
to ask you guys,
is there a lesson that
anybody in this room
can imagine that you
take into work, something
that your mother has given you
that you can see a connection
to in how you behave at work?
AUDIENCE: My mother
used to always say
what her mother
said to her, which
is if you can't
say something nice,
don't say anything at all.
And I think that's
really important
to sometimes be positive,
not be overly critical.
And certainly think
about it before you're
negative about stuff.
JILL EBSTEIN: Right.
No, that's a good one.
Just being positive
goes a long way.
Well, there's a lot of lessons.
There's a really funny story
in this book by Danny Brassell
It's called "Always Talking".
He describes his mother.
Actually it's so funny, I'm
going to read you a part of it.
And she's married to
a quiet librarian.
He is very happy to give his
wife the run of the house.
So he starts it off,
"Mom loves to talk.
It can drive a person nuts.
My mother has never
received a piece of mail
that she did not feel
compelled to read aloud
to anyone in the room.
'So Danny, you remember Mrs.
Hefflenagle,' she'll say.
'She died four years
before you were born.
Well, I just received a
letter from her daughter.
Let me read it to you.'
And then she'll read
about a letter of someone
I do not know about things
I do not care about.
And like Walt Disney, no matter
what travails she describes,
she always manages to
find a silver lining
to create a happy ending."
And then he describes
being in the car with her.
She's always talking.
"I don't ever remember sitting
in the car with my mother
throughout my childhood
where she did not play
some sort of game with us kids.
'Hey Danny, there's a Volkswagen
Bug', she pointed out while
smacking me in the arm.
'Hey Danny, look at the
license plates on the car.
How many different
states can you spot?
Hey Danny, what sounds
does your name start with?'
I'd make a D sound,
and she would
challenge me to find sounds
that started with that sound.
'Dairy Queen,' I'd
shout, 'Dunkin' Donuts.'
Yes, I was an obese child.
My poor father could
never get a word in,
nor anyone for that matter
when my mother began speaking.
'So honey, tell Daddy who
was on the plane with us.'
And as my father began
to open his mouth,
Mother would blurt out,
'The San Francisco Giants.
And honey, tell Danny
what they said to you.'
And Dad would make it another
fruitless attempt to speak.
Mom would share the
rest of the story."
So he says at the end, "Now Mom
always has something to say,
and I am now a motivational
speaker who gets paid to talk.
Who do you think I took after?"
Anyway, I think it's
really interesting
and may be helpful to
think about the lessons
that-- it could also be lessons
your father has given you.
But this book is for my
mom, dedicated to my mom.
So that was why I chose mothers.
But I think who we are at home
is mostly who we are at work.
And the lessons from our
parents are very much
a factor in who that person is.
Now I'm happy to
take any questions.
I could give you more stories,
but you've got the book,
so you could read it yourself.
But if you have any
questions or thoughts,
I am happy to take them.
AUDIENCE: I'll offer another
story, a lesson from my father
just because you
mentioned fathers.
I remember being a little
kid and complaining
about having to go to school.
And I've got a
17-year-old daughter now
who gives me the same
thing about complaining
about going to school.
But when I was a kid
and I was just so upset,
I didn't want to go to school.
It was a waste of my time.
I didn't like school.
And my dad said to me,
"I go to work every day.
I don't want to go
to work every day.
You just do it."
And that kind of stayed with me.
Sometimes there's
things you've got to do.
JILL EBSTEIN: Right.
It's not always
what you want to do.
It's sometimes
what you got to do.
No, that's true.
Sometimes when I get
into these rooms with--
especially when I've
gotten into room, a lot--
the sweet spot for
me in this book
is middle-aged women who
are contemplative and trying
to sort of think
back about their moms
and about their life.
And it's just so
interesting to see
how their decisions were driven
by a memory of their mother
and what they take with it.
And my daughter, I
was saying earlier--
some people weren't
here-- my daughter
wanted to write a piece.
And I was like, no, you
don't need to write a piece.
It's not about me.
It's about the world out there.
No, no, no, I want
to write a piece.
And she writes actually
a really good piece,
even though I
didn't want her to.
And her lesson, I always
said to her, Naomi,
responsibility goes up
and credit goes down.
And she works at
Boston Scientific.
And she always
tells me that those
are words that have always stuck
with her, responsibility up,
credit down.
Because you're
oftentimes on teams
which don't give enough
credit to the people
who are doing the work.
And it's very easy for someone
who is further up in the chain
to take the credit.
Not that it happens
here, but that
would be an inclination that
you could just be aware of.
I was happy to hear that some
words that I had said as a mom
actually made it into a piece.
But it's good.
So I think if you
guys are thinking
about a creative
present for your mother,
you could give her a copy of the
book, or your copy of the book.
And you could write her a little
note, as people have done.
I had one woman who
said to me, "I would not
have been able to write
a piece for this book
because I would have been
all about dissing my mom."
So I said, "OK, tell
me about your mom."
"Well, she's 94."
"What does she do?"
"Well, she plays lots
of games, canasta."
She listed a whole bunch
of games that she plays.
And I said to her--
I happened to know a little bit
about this woman, not a lot.
I said, "Tell me
what you like to do."
She said, "Well,
I play games too."
And she actually teaches games.
That's one of her hobbies that
she gets paid to teach games.
So I said to her, "And you
can't find any gift there
about your mother
in her 90s and then
you being a games
player as well?"
And then she saw me
a couple weeks later
and she said to me, "Thank
you, because I'm actually going
to thank my mom for that."
And she didn't think she
had any thanks in her,
but she actually did.
That has come up in
so many different ways
where people have had a
chance to thank their mother.
So it's late February,
last day of February.
Mother's Day is in May.
And you have a couple of months.
You could write your
mother a little note
and give her the
book and she probably
would think it's about
one of the nicest
presents she could have.
Thank you guys for coming.
I know you guys are busy.
I'm happy to take questions.
But if you don't have
questions, then I'll
let you guys get back to work.
AUDIENCE: I guess I
have one question.
Did you notice the difference
between mothers and sons
versus mothers and
daughters in the pieces?
JILL EBSTEIN: Not so much
actually, I really did not.
The men who stepped
up and wanted to write
were, for the most part, men
who were very comfortable
sharing their emotions
and didn't have a--
so I would say that I
didn't see so much of that.
I actually originally
thought this
would be a book about
mothers and daughters.
And my son who is my copy
editor said, "Well, sons
are going to want to write
about their mothers too."
And it was like a new idea to
me that sons would actually
speak about their mothers.
And so then I went
running around.
I'm like, well I can't just
have two men in the book
or one man in the book.
So then I went around
and started asking men,
do you want to write
about your mother?
Their biggest constraint was
just either time or people
very uncomfortable with
their writing skills.
That's a big theme I have in
these books is people will say,
well, I have ideas,
but I'm not a writer.
And I always say, you
don't have to be a writer.
I will help you.
You have to have thoughts,
but we can take your thoughts
and we can make a piece.
And they're so happy afterwards
because they wouldn't
have done it on their own.
I see a difference
in age more than I
see a difference in gender.
The older you get,
the more appreciative.
Some of the younger
stories are angsty.
AUDIENCE: I think that last
comment about the age thing
seems to me, as you get older,
you experience more of life
and you bump into these things.
A lot of the lessons that I
feel like I'm starting to learn
or as I understand myself and
go inside myself and learn more
about my own character and
personality and the way
I handle situations gives me
an appreciation for the way
my mum handled herself.
Went through a divorce.
My father's business went
bankrupt before that,
and then she went
through a divorce.
But the way she
handled herself--
And the one thing that struck
me through this whole thing
was the way that she sings all
day long around the house doing
anything.
In that sense I carry that
same musical sense with me.
So I just catch myself
sometimes doing the dishes
while the kids are getting
ready to go to school
and just doing the same
kind of thing, any song.
It could be one of
the kids' tunes.
It could be ABBA, which
my mom used to love,
or whatever it is.
And I'll do this.
I'm like, I'm crazy.
But then I turn around
and I see the kids
doing the same thing
walking around the house,
singing to themselves
while they're doing tasks.
And it's just a cascading
like, I don't know,
it's genetic or just crazy.
JILL EBSTEIN: But
that's a lovely thing
to pass though generations.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And I think the age
tie in there was just
being able to recognize that.
You get to a certain
age where you
start to see all these
different pieces of your mother.
And the things that
you hated at one time,
then you're either experiencing
it with your own daughters
or sons, or you just
learn more about yourself
and how you handle situations.
JILL EBSTEIN:
Right, that's true.
That's definitely true.
Lacey?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'll
just second that.
It occurred to me that right--
I was born when my
mother was almost 30,
so I haven't gotten
to the point yet where
I am really doing any of the
things that I saw her doing.
And I've been married
almost four months now,
and I'm just starting
to see things
where I'm like, oh my gosh, I'm
doing this just like my mom.
Or like all these
things she used
to remind me about
I'm like, oh, this
is where it's
useful, that I'm just
starting to be in the kind of
situations that I saw her in.
JILL EBSTEIN: Right.
We love that as parents.
We love when we see that
our kids don't think
that what we did was just
crazy but there actually
was some reason behind it all.
Well keep your eyes open for
ways you're like your parents.
And then if they're
all flattering,
you can let them know, because
it's always good as a parent
to have a moment of recognition.
Well thank you all
for coming today.
I appreciate that.
Take care.
[APPLAUSE]